The mean is obviously 25.
In fact, every element over here is 5 times as large as any element over here.
Now, how does this affect the variance?
Well, when we compute the differences from the mean, they're going to be 5 times as large.
When we square them, they will be 25 times as large.
As a result, the variance is 25 times as large as over here--it's 50.
And we can quickly check this.
Obviously, there is no difference for 25 in the middle.
20 and 25 are 5 apart--the square of this is 25.
Same for 30. 15 and 25 are 10 apart. The square is 100.
We add those up--we get 250--and now we divide by 5 to get back our 50.
The standard deviation is 7.071,
and that's exactly 5 times as large as the standard deviation over here.
If this is 25 times as large as this one,
then the square root of it will be just 5 times as large as this one.
You can easily verify that this is the square root of 50.